Chris Hardwick: This is
the Star Wars: The Force Awakens panel
Um...
[Crowd cheering]
I know a lot of you start --
Oh, there is the graphic
that proves I'm not lying.
I'm not a liar.
I know a lot of you guys waited
a long time to be here.
I mean like ... decades, really.
And, so I'm also here to tell you that
you're not gonna disappointed.
And I want you to know before we get into this,
really quickly and its not about me,
but I just want you to know how special
and how emotional this is for me.
I am old enough to have seen
Star Wars in the theatre, which is--
[Cheering in crowd]
Why would you cheer that.
It sucks to get older,
but here we are.
My Dad took me, I stood on the seat,
it completely changed my life,
and informed pretty much
everything that came after,
I know the experience is
the same for you.
So, there's gonna be some amazing things
that are gonna happen,
and someday you will look back,
and get to tell --
Your grandkids will be like,
"Shut up, Grandpa."
"I was at the Force Awakens panel, and --"
[Laughter]
"Back in Ought-Fifteen."
And they'll be like, "Shut up."
So, I want you to really
think about this,
and experience it, and enjoy it
as it's happening, ok?
Because this is an experience
that just this group of us will have
for the rest of our lives.
So, uh --
[Audience cheering]
J.J. Abrams:
Haha, you're welcome.
Hardwick: Oh, did you
give them donuts?
Kathleen Kennedy:
Got the donuts and the coffee.
Abrams: Donuts!
Lawrence Kasdan:
Thank you.
Hardwick: I mean, I feel like
they were gonna see the movie anyway,
but that's very nice of you.
"I was on the fence,
but he gave me donuts.
So I guess I'll go
see Star Wars."
Um --
I wanna start --
I'm sure they were good. Alright.
Kathleen, I want to start with you,
and I want you to talk
a little bit about --
I mean, Star Wars was one of the things
that helped usher in the Comic-Con age.
So, can you talk about the fandom,
and the presence of Star Wars
throughout the years?
Kathleen Kennedy: Now, obviously,
I think a lot of people out there know,
that Star Wars is 100% dependent
on the fans in this room
and all over the world,
since 1976 --
[Cheering and clapping]
Kennedy: In fact -- in fact,
when the movie was ready to come out,
it was really the fans
that built the momentum
around the release
of New Hope.
So we are right back,
in full circle,
and we want to say thank you,
to all of you.
Hardwick: Yeah.
Abrams: Yeah.
[Clapping and cheering]
Hardwick: So, just to
give us a timeline,
'cause we're still
a handful of months out
from being able to see this,
are you freaking out?
Where are you in production?
At what point?
Abrams: We are --
we're in -- we're editing,
we have a cut of the movie,
we're doing -- uh --
We're in this extraordinary moment
where we're doing fine tuning,
and I say extraordinary, because
in this business, a lot of times,
there are release dates
before there are scripts,
and to have the time
and to have Disney give us the time
to do it right is not a small thing.
And so, we're working hard to make the movie
more of what it wants to be.
Hardwick: Great.
Um, Mr. Kasdan.
Lawrence Kasdan: Yes.
Hardwick: Welcome, by the way,
I don't think you've been
to a Comic-Con before, have you?
[Clapping and cheering]
Kasdan: Thank you.
Harwick: He's --
Technically, you're our dad,
in a weird sort of way.
Kasdan: Not in age, [indistinct].
Hardwick: No. But, can you talk
a little bit about, when you guys --
I mean, first of all, the thing I think
you need to understand about J.J. is that
this -- he really cares about this a lot.
It's as important to him
as it is to you and to me,
and so, I want to talk about the experience
of you guys coming together.
You bringing in legacy Star Wars,
and then, J.J., you --
taking on the responsibility
of meeting together and figuring out how to
bring new characters into the universe.
Kasdan: Yeah, well, I --
the guy that brought me in
is the genius that
brings us all here.
It was George Lucas.
He was --
[Cheering]
Kasdan: Absolute, breakthrough,
monster genius,
and none of us would be here
if it weren't for him.
And he called me, and said,
"Will you do this for me?"
And we started to do
"Empire Strikes Back,"
and then we did
"Return of the Jedi."
And then thirty years passed.
And those movies just, like, never went
out of my life or my consciousness.
And then a call came again.
Said, "Will you come back?
And meet these characters
again, thirty years later?"
And so there wasn't even any disjunction
between my life and this timeline.
And when we got J.J.
to say he would do that,
I went berserk.
Because I --
Abrams: In a bad way.
Kasdan: In a bad way.
I thought he was the funniest, most talented,
most perfect choice for this movie.
And then he and I wound up
spending a year,
walking around, writing,
figuring it out,
and it's been a total gas.
Hardwick: J.J., how do you
push the fandom out of the way,
to focus on the work?
When you're working with Larry.
Abrams: I mean --
Star Wars is, like you said,
it's something that
is so deeply ingrained
and so important
to so many people --
You know, I asked my mom to make me
a Jawa costume for my thirteenth Halloween,
and uh -- I did the eyes,
but she did the costume.
And it was great.
And, uh --
I've been a fan since
I was a kid, a little kid.
And -- there is nothing normal
about getting to write a movie
with Lawrence Kasdan.
There's nothing normal about
getting to work with Kathleen Kennedy,
or to direct a Star Wars movie.
I've sat down with John Williams
to show him scenes
from a Star Wars movie
he hadn't seen yet.
That I directed.
There's nothing normal
about any of what's been happening.
Including this moment.
And by the way, you guys look awesome
and thank you for waiting so long to be here.
It's really -- thank you.
Kasdan: Yes, thank you.
[Audience and panel clapping]
[Audience cheering]
Hardwick: I think --
I think, one of the things that's been
so [indistinct] to watch is that
you really seeded out
a lot of the stuff.
I mean, you put stuff out
on Instagram,
and I know you made
this great Omaze video,
and when people started to see
glimpses of what you were building,
and they saw, "holy crap, he's actually built,
like, these are practical effects.
We're seeing, like,
real things, and--"
which is astonishing
these days.
Abrams: Well, it's
an important piece of this,
and we've talked
about it a little bit,
but we did this video
for UNICEF, through
this group, Omaze,
and it was a really
successful endeavor.
We raised $5 million,
thanks to your help,
for UNICEF
Innovation Labs
and it's a big deal.
So thank you for that.
Um -- But when we first
started shooting the movie,
we did this video
that went out
where I was -- we were all in Abu Dhabi,
and I was standing there,
and there was a creature
in the scene,
and some people, uh --
There it is.
Um, and,
some people were [indistinct],
"oh, great, you made creatures,"
and other people thought,
"oh, it's a CG thing," and --
Uh --
We wanted to show you
it wasn't CG,
and this is just one
of many characters,
so we actually brought
this character, we call Bobbajo,
as a nickname, so let's --
should we bring Bobbajo out?
See what happens?
Hardwick: Yeah, I think so, absolutely.
Abrams: Let's see.
[Audience cheering]
Abrams: All right.
Everyone cross their fingers.
Cross your fingers.
Here we go.
All right.
So, this character --
Here he comes.
Hardwick: Amazing.
Let's see.
No, I don't want --
Abrams: This character was
built by Neal Scanlan
and the creature department.
Let's see if this works.
Hardwick: Yes, thanks. All right.
Kennedy: Here we go.
Thank you.
Hardwick: So --
Kennedy: I think so.
Abrams: Want to talk
about Neal Scanlan?
Kennedy: Ok, yeah, Neal --
Neal Scanlan...
These guys have done
an unbelievable job, as you can see.
We're gonna hope that he does not fall off
the stage here, so I'm just kinda looking--
Hardwick: I'm keeping
an eye on him,
and I will give my life
to save him.
Kennedy: Yeah, he --
[Audience laughter]
Bobbajo's a little slow,
so we're just gonna
give him a little....
Abrams: Huh!
Kennedy: A bit worrisome here.
Hardwick: So --
Abrams: How's it going?
Good to see you. Hi, how are you.
Hello, how you doin'. Don't eat that.
Don't eat that.
So, uh --
This is one of, uh --
of hundreds of creatures
that they built
for this film.
And what's amazing is
seeing the people who, uh --
operate these things.
And the real benefit
of having creatures like this --
and you can see
that character right there,
you know, there are five people
who are operating that creature.
And a lot of these creatures are even,
are background creatures.
They're not even
the main event.
But what's so cool
about them
is it gives the actors
who are in scenes
things to actually deal with,
interact with, play with, respond to.
Uh --
It also helps --
even things like light,
the way light reflects
on the set,
and on the characters.
So it's a big deal.
All these characters, these creatures
you're seeing, were built --
Kennedy: No, and it's amazing, too,
because even though we're not --
we decided not to use CG,
the robotic technology has
really advanced, as you can see.
[Audience clapping and cheering]
Hardwick: Well, yeah, I mean --
And especially --
[Audience cheering intensifies]
[A smaller creature on the larger creature
makes a short honking noise]
Kennedy: Here he comes.
Hardwick: Oh, he's going to walk all the way
back across. Please don't fall this time.
Abrams: This is where it gets ugly. But --
Kennedy: This is not easy.
Hardwick: For anyone who grew up
with the original Star Wars,
and it was part of the charm
of the movie,
was being able to see these characters look
as though they were -- had come to life.
And I think CG certainly has its place,
but seeing a practical effect --
I mean, even seeing that, seeing him
wiggle his nose in that way,
it does something emotionally that reminds us
of the first time we saw Star Wars.
Kennedy: And the friends,
and the friends up here [indistinct].
Hardwick: And the little friends,
along the side.
[Abrams chuckles]
Abrams: And, there you go. Uh oh.
Kennedy: Ok. Oh, you resting?
Abrams: Oh dear God.
[Kennedy and Hardwick laugh]
Kennedy: Oh!
Hardwick: Yeah.
Abrams: I knew it.
Hardwick: That's ok, I'll wait.
All right. Excellent.
And would you -- you said
this was Neal Scanlan.
Kennedy: Yeah.
Abrams: Yeah, Neal Scanlan and his team --
the most amazing creature shop.
Hardwick: I'm fine.
Abrams: And there he goes.
Hardwick: All right, and there we go.
Huge hand for Bobbajo.
[Panel and audience clapping, cheering]
I mean, essentially,
this is the -- when you're working
with these types of practical effects,
I mean, there's -- it's basically just
whatever limits your imagination has, right?
I mean, you can say, 'we want
to build this, I want to see this,
I need to populate
the world in this way.'
Abrams: Well, here's the thing.
There's -- of course, it's Star Wars,
there's going to be
a ton of visual effects.
There will be CG,
you can't avoid it.
And -- but the important thing for us
was that we make this authentic,
that we tell the story,
and allow the actors to interact with
and be on a set with
as much authentic, real,
tangible construction as possible.
So sets, props, creatures.
And it just --
it helped the entire process
look and feel like it was
actually on screen, because it was.
Hardwick: So, sort of the way
the panel's gonna work a little bit
is, we're gonna --
[Scattered applause]
Oh, nice. Hey, sure,
give it up. Come on.
Abrams: Authenticity!
[Audience cheering and clapping]
Hardwick: We're gonna take questions
sort of throughout the panel,
so that everyone can
sort of focus a little bit.
So let's go and take a couple of questions
for Larry and J.J. and Kathleen.
Um, this first, uh -- hello.
What's your name?
Like I don't know.
>> [In scratchy voice]
Batman!
Hardwick: Yeah, I know it's Batman.
That was a dumb question.
[Panel and audience laughter]
Hardwick: Yeah.
What's your real name?
>> Batman!
Hardwick: Batman. Yeah, ok, that's what I thought.
So, Mr. Batman,
what is your question?
>> [Maintaining scratchy voice]
My question is for Mr. J.J. Abrams.
[Hardwick laughs]
[Audience laughs]
And it is, what influences did you take,
what amalgam of concepts
did you draw upon,
to make this film?
Whether it be the comics,
video games,
even other movies?
Hardwick: First of all, way to commit.
That was amazing.
[Audience and panel laughter]
I'm very proud that you got through
that whole thing, as Batman.
J.J.?
Abrams: Um --
I couldn't really
understand you.
No, I could. I could.
I got it. I got it.
Hardwick: What he said was,
[imitates scratchy voice, speaking unintelligibly]
Abrams: It was good.
Uh -- uh --
First of all, awesome costume,
and great question.
What I think -- and Larry,
I think you could answer this as well.
I mean, we tried to sit down
and ask ourselves,
what feels right?
And the only real mandate
we had was,
what is --
what delights us?
Doesn't mean it has to be fun all the time,
and sort of, you know, forever silly,
but it means it has
to be compelling.
And obviously
we treated the films,
you know, IV, V, and VI,
especially which --
those were things that,
you know, for me,
were the films
I grew up with,
um, we treated those
as canon.
And, by the way,
that Larry wrote.
It's insane. To ask --
to be writing a script,
a Star Wars script,
with Larry Kasden.
Uh -- you know, it's like,
"What would Han say --?"
[Imitates Kasden]
"I'll tell you what Han would say."
[Laughter]
[Still imitating Kasden]
"I wrote Han. I know what Han sounds like."
[As self] : That's a perfect
impersonation of Larry Kasden.
Kasden: But when we were --
obviously, he can't do me at all.
[Laughter]
But, we won't mention it.
He -- When we were talking
about the light, we just --
we're talking about, it's something
as simple as the texture of a wall.
The fact that a person
casts a shadow,
creature casts the shadow
as he comes through the room.
You can feel that
those are real weapons,
and those are real, uh,
stormtroopers back there.
It was a happy moment.
We had been --
we were writing very fast,
we were writing
really hard, and --
In one month, we were walking around
Santa Monica, figuring out the story.
And just a couple months later,
we're sitting in the bay of a Star Destroyer,
with stormtroopers
drilling in front of us.
And still writing, of course.
And -- it was all real.
It was all real.
And we said, "Well,
we got that part right.
We got that part right."
Abrams: It -- the answer was,
Batman, that --
[Hardwick chuckles]
[Audience laughter]
We wanted to tell a story
that would make us feel,
and that would be something
that would feel like a continuum
of the incredible story
that George started.
Hardwick: "I had the weirdest dream
that I was in front of 7,000 people,
and then Batman asked
a question about Star Wars."
Like, that's the strangest --
that's my life.
Uh - hah - what is your -
thank you very much.
Uh, what is your name?
>> Hello, my name is
Lynette Grant,
and this is a dream come true
in so many ways, so.
Great to be here.
Hardwick: Thank you. Of course.
What is your question?
>> This question is
actually for J.J., and...
Star Wars is precious to me.
I sat on the couch with my daddy
when I was a little girl,
and we watched Star Wars,
and Star Trek, and Battle Beyond the Stars.
It's a precious legacy,
not only to me,
but I'm pretty sure to a couple
of people in this room. [Chuckles]
When you get such a heavy burden,
and you have this precious legacy,
and you have to pay homage
to that, to us and the fans,
and then you've got this
new generation that you're building,
and trying to bring this alive for them,
how do you approach that?
Hardwick: No pressure.
Abrams: I think, honestly, I feel more pressure answering your question than I do --
Uh -- no, it's a great question.
It really is. Uh --
I watched Star Wars
with my parents, too.
It was very much -- uh --
it meant very much to me,
what it means to so many of you.
And I feel like the answer that I can give you,
the only answer I can say is,
because we love it,
and we care about it so much,
our job is to not be
blinded by that.
Meaning, you can't just be a fan
and then say, well, you're gonna
make a movie, 'cause you're a fan.
It's not enough. You gotta really say,
what is a -- what's the story?
I mean, I will tell you
from personal experience,
when you're directing a scene
on the Millennium Falcon,
it doesn't make the scene good.
Now, it's bitchin' that it's on the Millennium Falcon.
[Audience laughter]
Like, you want a scene on the Mille --
If I could make a suggestion:
direct scenes on the Millennium Falcon.
'Cause it's hugely helpful.
But it doesn't make the scene
automatically good.
So you have to ask, what --
it's literally Storytelling 101.
What do the characters want?
Who are they?
What makes this interesting?
What's unexpected?
How do you make this --
it has to be fun, it has to be scary.
It has to -- the power of what's come before
is so infectious and so deep,
that you have to harness it,
but you can't be blinded by it.
And it's a constant thing,
working with Larry and with Kathy,
there were all these
checks and balances, saying,
"That's really cool,
but what does it mean?"
You know, "why are we doing this?"
And so, I hope I've answered
your question by saying, we tried --
we worked as hard as we possibly could,
and I can't wait to show you the movie.
Hardwick: Awesome.
Abrams: Thank you.
Hardwick: Ok, so one more question
for this section. Hello!
>> Yeah, my question's for J.J.
I just wanted to know,
You did such a great job with Star Trek,
the first two movies.
Are you gonna do each individual
movie as a standalone,
or are they gonna be tie-ins,
or it is gonna be a serious arc?
Abrams: Well, I'll let Kathy answer that,
because Kathy is the one who oversees
every possible thing at Lucasfilm.
Kennedy: Well, obviously
with the Saga films,
which -- J.J. is starting the first,
which is the Force Awakens,
8 and 9 will be part of that saga.
But we're also making
anthology films, standalone movies.
[Audience cheering]
And Gareth Edwards actually starts
shooting in about three weeks.
So the first one will go
into production very soon.
Hardwick: Excellent.
Thank you very much.
So, obviously you had made
a brief statement, a handful of days ago,
just sort of let people know, like, you know,
we're not really ready to show footage yet.
Um, but --
Is there anything that you could?
I mean, is --
Abrams: Yes.
Now, here's the thing.
Now here's the thing --
uh, the truth is,
we aren't ready to show you
scenes from the movie,
or a new trailer,
and we really want to wait
and do the trailer later in the fall.
But the -- we knew that
this was too important,
coming to you, who care about this
and love this so much.
And we wanted to bring something that was
as unique and unexpected as we could.
We put together a piece
that you're gonna see,
that we hoped would bring you
into the process a little bit,
of what it was like to make this movie
and get to see some of
the people who are doing it.
So, uh, we have that.
Hardwick: Yes, please. I saw
this last night, and I cried. Alright.
[Laughter]
Yes, I know.
Mike's already crying.
Alright, so, let's see this footage,
and I think you will be very happy.
I mean, that is never-before-seen
footage of behind-the-scenes
of The Force Awakens.
And also,
I do want to point out, there is a very
special guest here in the audience.
Peter Mayhew is out here.
[Audience cheering]
Uh -- there he is.
There's Peter, over there,
by the microphone.
[Audience clapping
and cheering]
This is my notebook,
this is the notebook that I have.
This is my notebook.
[Panelists chuckling]
My notebook. Uh --
Alright. So, now we're gonna
meet some of the cast.
Some of whom, I know you guys
got to talk to a little bit at Celebration.
So let's bring them out.
Playing Finn,
John Boyega is here!
[Audience clapping
and cheering]
Also Daisy Ridley!
[Audience clapping
and cheering]
And as Poe Dameron,
Oscar Isaac!
[Audience clapping
and cheering]
Welcome. Oh yeah,
that's right! Ok, ok good.
You have to bring out
your own name cards now.
Female in audience: Oscar!
Hardwick: Oh-my-god!
Ah, welcome!
Oscar Isaac: Hi, everybody!
Hardwick: How're you guys doing?
[Boyega, Ridley, Isaac,
"good, so good" etc]
Hardwick: John, um,
can you talk a little bit about
you're -- you got to
walk the floor a little bit.
John Boyega: Yeah, yeah.
Hardwick: And so, how is it,
being on both sides?
Like, you know, sort of,
pre-Star-Wars now,
Star Wars --
are you feeling -- does it feel
any different, being a fan?
Boyega: I mean, let's just say
this is really complicated,
buying a black series
Star Wars figure out here.
[Hardwick et al chuckle]
I can't get through the crowd, honestly.
Thank you, J.J.
Ah, but, it's been awesome.
I mean, uh,
we walk the floor, we got to meet
you guys, we got to meet some fans
by the LucasFilm booth.
And it was amazing fun.
Oh, you were there?
Hey, man! Hey!
Hardwick: But they didn't know that was you, right?
They didn't know that was you underneath --
Boyega: Oh, yeah, yeah, so, yeah,
this is me, walking through
the Star Wars Celebration Hall,
obviously, I was in disguise.
I couldn't afford the rest of the costume,
But, uh, you know, it still worked.
And that guy totally didn't know
that was me, by the way.
He was just like, "dude,
why do you have my saber?"
[Hardwick and Ridley chuckle]
But we had a great time.
Oh, that was you?
Oh, that was you in the picture!
Daisy Ridley: Hey!
Boyega: Hey, man!
Hardwick: That was literally you?
Boyega: How you doing? Oh, hey!
[Boyega clapping]
Hey!
Hardwick: Oh, it was so much funnier
when we thought you didn't know!
Boyega: Yeah, yeah,
I thought you didn't know.
[Audience member speaks
but is not near a microphone]
Boyega: Oh, you shook my hand.
Well, yeah, guys, yeah, man.
Thank you so much, man!
I love you guys, honestly.
That was a great experience.
I enjoyed myself.
Hardwick: Yeah. What are the --
actually, the odds are pretty good,
that that guy would be here.
What am I saying?
Boyega: I know, right?
Yeah, yeah!
Hardwick: "What are the odds a Star Wars fan
would be at the Star Wars panel?"
Ah, life's crazy.
[Audience member speaks
but is not near a microphone]
Boyega: What?
[Audience member speaks
but is not near a microphone]
Boyega: Oh, thank you man,
I appreciate that.
Abrams: We're getting very complicated.
Boyega: Yeah, yeah.
Hardwick: It is. I know, that guy just
wants to have a conversation now.
What are you doing later?
Boyega: Yeah. Hey, we'll talk later!
Hardwick: Wanna get a taco?
What do you wanna do?
Um --
Daisy, I want to talk
about your tr--
Ridley: Woo!
Hardwick: Daisy, yes, please.
[Audience clapping
and cheering]
Let's talk about the physical demands --
Ridley: Yes.
Hardwick: that you've had,
as compared to other stuff you've done.
What was the training element like for you,
and did it change you?
Ridley: Firstly, we can't really compare it
to other stuff I've done,
'cause I've not really done other stuff.
Um -- it was, like -- I think,
going into acting, you always hope
that physically, you can change yourself,
as well as emotionally
embody a character.
So, to be able to have, like, solid months of training,
though difficult, was amazing.
Like, our incredible stunt team --
oh my God, I've never seen those pictures.
Um, uh,
like the most incredible stunt team,
me and John got to work together a lot.
And then, as you've seen the teaser:
we were running through
125-degree heat.
And those explosions were real.
I mean, John, then, had it harder.
I'd just like to thank J.J. Abrams
for filming in Abu Dhabi, in the desert,
and making me wear
a stormtrooper outfit.
[Hardwick et al laugh]
Boyega: Thank you, J.J.
You're honestly understanding.
[Audience laughs]
Hardwick: It's great for all the fans,
it's great for all the fans, 'cause they're like,
"oh, he's really going there,
he's really shooting it!"
And the actors are like, "can we just do
like a green-screen thing? I mean, like..."
Boyega: Right, yeahh!
Ridley: But yeah, it was amazing,
and I think the look of it, hopefully, pays off.
And hopefully my dress reveals my guns,
'cause I worked hard for these.
[Hardwick et al laugh]
Isaac: Yes.
Hardwick: Oscar Isaac,
who's playing Poe Dameron.
[Audience cheers]
Isaac: Thank you.
Hardwick: So, you said Poe was the --
I believe the quote was,
"Best friggin' pilot in the galaxy."
Isaac: Yes.
Hardwick: Were you given
advice on your piloting?
Did anything help you
become a better pilot?
Isaac: Ah -- well yeah, you know,
as an excited, eager actor,
you know, I wanted to talk
to Harrison about piloting,
and about,
how should I do it, you know?
Is there any special things that I should do?
Just, how do you work the controls?
And he said, um...
"It's fake."
[Hardwick et al laugh]
"And also, it's in space,
so the same stuff doesn't really apply."
[Hardwick chuckles]
Isaac: And I said, 'got it. I can do that.'
But you know, I think really it's --
it was taking on,
you know, the character of Poe,
he takes on that legacy,
not only of Han, but of Luke,
of being these heroic pilots.
'Cause if you think about it,
these characters, ah,
they lived those stories
that we all grew up with.
They grew up at the same time
as those stories, you know? I mean...
Poe was probably, he was there
watching on Yarvin, you know,
when the medal ceremony
was happening,
thinking, "I want to be that.
I want to be a hero.
And I want to take up that mantle."
And, uh, I think that's
what he does, you know?
He -- even sometimes
recklessly so.
Um, but uh -- so yeah,
really connecting it to that old world,
it was special.
Hardwick: Great! I want to give some of the fans
opportunity to ask you guys some questions.
So let's go into the audience.
Ask a couple questions.
Here they come.
Bounding up to the -- hello!
>> Hello there.
Hardwick: What is your name?
>> [Male speaker] My name is Ryan.
Hardwick: Hey, Ryan.
>> [Female speaker] I'm Currin (?).
Hardwick: Hello, what's your question?
>> [Male] This question is for J.J.
What we really like about your Star Trek films
is the diversity of the cast.
>> [Female] And we would like to know,
do you plan on having any Asian characters
join the cast in any upcoming films?
[Audience cheers]
Abrams: Uh --
First of all, I want to say, go Asians.
[Laughter and cheering]
I mean --
I think I --
Hardwick: 'S the right answer.
Abrams: I think the whole room
feels that way.
Uh -- uh --
Here's the thing. I'm not casting
the movies that are coming up,
but if I were to, I would
cast them as only Asian.
[Someone snorts with laughter]
[Hardwick belly-laughs]
But, uh -- I think you'll be happy
to see, when you see this film,
there are Asians in this film.
So, I was involved
in the casting of this movie,
and, there --
but honestly, the truth is,
we didn't write the character of Finn
to be, you know, any color.
We didn't write the character
of Rey to be any color.
We, you know --
we just cast this movie,
knowing that it was important that we --
[Audience clapping]
We wanted the movie to look
the way the world looks.
And, uh, I think it's important that people
see themselves represented in film.
I think it's not a small thing.
So I completely understand, and think
your question is hugely important,
and it was a big consideration.
But I'm really proud of
the cast we ended up with,
literally these actors
are extraordinary.
And when you're working as long
and as hard as we all have on this movie,
and you're in editing,
and you see the choices you have,
in terms of performances,
take to take, uh,
I could not be more grateful
to all you guys for the work you did.
So, thanks for your question.
Kennedy: And I will add to that --
I'll peek around the corner here and add to that,
that there is every intention to carry on
exactly what J.J.'s talking about,
in all the Star Wars movies
that we're going to make.
[Audience cheers and applauds]
Hardwick: Excellent.
Abrams: Thank you.
Hardwick: Good tag-team question.
Yes, sir.
>> Hi, Chris. My name is Monty Goulet.
My question is for J.J.
J.J., when you did the previous unreleased IPs
such as Lost and Fringe,
you did a lot of transmedia.
And now you're doing transmedia for Star Wars,
one of the biggest IPs ever,
with a big, expansive universe.
Is there anything you would do,
to take away from Star Wars,
when you build a new IP
again in the future?
Abrams: Uh --
Kennedy: Uh, don't answer that.
[Kennedy et al laugh]
Abrams: What Kathy doesn't
want me to say -- no.
This is what I think.
Uh, and I --
I'm interested that you use
the term "IP" so frequently.
[Panelists chuckle]
But I will say this:
I don't think of Star Wars as a --
I don't even know
how to answer that question.
I appreciate it, but the answer
I could give you is...
This is a story. And these are
characters that we love.
And so, I'm -- none of us, I think, are thinking
about it from the outside in, like that.
And it's weird, because
you come to something like this,
and you want to
make everyone happy,
and you want to show something
that makes everyone excited.
But the truth is, we're just working really hard
to make a movie and tell a story,
and when things come up that we know
we need to do to sell it, and market it,
we want that to be
as authentic as the piece itself.
So, I'm not quite sure
what the strategy would be.
But I know that if we thought of it as an IP,
I think it would end up being a very different film.
Hardwick: [chuckles] Mr. Goulet
suffers from lawyer syndrome.
He can only talk about it in IP.
Abrams: Monty hates me.
I'm so sorry. Ok thanks.
Hardwick: Are we good?
You got a thumbs-up and a heart.
Abrams: Thumbs-up.
Thumbs-up for Monty.
Hardwick: Emoji heart.
Yes, what is your name, sir?
>> Oh, hi. My name is Scott.
And my question is for all of you guys,
depending on if you can answer this.
[Ridley laughs]
>> Thanks. Um --
Hardwick: "Can I live with you?"
[Panelists laugh]
>> Anyways, um,
my question is,
what's it like to work with the original cast,
the legends, say, like, Mark Hamill,
Harrison Ford, and Carrie Fisher?
Hardwick: Yeah, let's throw that to the cast,
what it was like for you guys.
Let's start with Oscar.
Isaac: Uh, uh, um -- Harrison thought
I was wearing a wig.
[Panelists laugh]
So that was fun, that was cool.
Hardwick: What about you, Daisy?
Ridley: Um, it was --
Going from an outside fan,
going into filming Star Wars,
I think working with the legends
that have gone --
have already made this kind of universe
and are coming back to it,
was everything we could have
hoped for, and more.
They're funny and
warm and welcoming,
and made us feel as part
of the universe as they already are.
So it was great.
Hardwick: Excellent. John?
Boyega: I have to say,
my greatest memory
was taking Harrison Ford to a Nigerian
restaurant in Southeast London.
[Ridley laughs]
And walking in and seeing all these Nigerians absolutely frozen at the sight of Harrison Ford.
And this guy comes up to him and says,
"Are you Harrison Ford?"
Harrison Ford goes,
"I used to be."
[Panelists laugh]
[Audience applauds]
Hardwick: Thank you very much
for your question.
One more question for now.
Yes, what is your name?
>> Yeah, my name's Mario,
and this is for the whole panel,
including Chris.
Hardwick: What?
>> Alright. If you guys were Jedis in real life,
what color would each of your lightsabers be?
[Hardwick gasps]
[Audience claps]
Kennedy: I'm gonna go
to blue, right away.
Abrams: I have to -- I -- listen.
I'm gonna say red.
Kennedy: Oh.
Abrams: I have to say it. Red.
It would be. I know.
Kasdan: I would like to have
the first black --
Ridley: Ooh!
Kennedy: Oh!
Boyega: I'd say, gold.
Ridley: Then I'm gonna say silver.
Isaac: Like, a rainbow-colored?
[Panelists laugh]
Hardwick: Yeah. That's the best answer.
Boyega: Woo!
Hardwick: That was the best ans--
better than what I --
Thank you.
Hey, and this is you.
Um, alright, so,
we've seen the Light side,
but what you guys haven't seen yet
is a little taste of the Dark side. So --
[Audience cheers wildly]
[Isaac makes 'mwa-ha-ha' vocalization]
Boyega: Hey, Daisy.
Hardwick: I would like to
bring out some people that, uh --
let's call them
relevant to your interests. Um --
As Kylo Ren, please
welcome Adam Driver!
[Audience clapping
and cheering]
As General Hux,
Domhnall Gleeson!
[Audience clapping
and cheering]
And as Captain Phasma,
Gwendoline Christie!
[Audience clapping
and cheering]
Alright, so let's start
with Adam. Um --
So, the images that we see, like,
we've seen some intense images,
we've seen exciting images,
can you tell us a little bit about
your character's connection to the Dark side?
Gwendoline Christie: Ah, well,
Captain Phasma is a First Order --
[Audience laughs]
I'm just speaking wildly.
Hardwick: Let her go. Yeah.
Christie: This is so out of control, right now.
Hardwick: This is --
[Audience cheers loudly]
Can I just say something, though?
You know you're on Game of Thrones, right?
[Audience cheering continues]
Christie: Game of who?
Hardwick: [chuckles]
Ok. Nevermind.
Domhnall Gleeson: You're on
Game of Thrones. That's amazing.
Hardwick: Adam. What can you tell us
about your connection to the Dark side?
Can you tell us anything?
Adam Driver: No.
Hardwick: Ok.
[Panelists and audience laugh]
Now, Domhnall, the --
[Panelists laugh]
There is a -- a sort of an unspoken tradition
uh -- in the original Star Wars,
of bad guys being these, sort of,
ehh, let's call them
'humorless British types,' and kind of --
Gleeson: Are you really moving on to me?
And you're letting him get away with that?
Hardwick: Well, I can't -- he's not --
there's nothing he can say. Yeah. That was it.
Isaac: Like, come on,  you gotta say something.
Adam, say something.
Driver: Uh, I, um...
what do you want me to say?
[Panelists and audience chuckling]
Hardwick: Who are you?
Driver: That's a good question.
Hardwick: Yeah, see, he doesn't even --
Driver: Good question.
Hardwick: Can you tell us anything about --
Gleeson: Oh, man.
Driver: I mean --
I mean, what can I say?
We didn't really have a lot
of conversations about, um,
bad or evil, actually,
when we were shooting it.
It was more, 'what do you think is
the difference between being bad and being right?'
I think, which is
a huge difference.
Someone who thinks they're bad
is almost kind of like a selfish thing.
And it's mostly about them, and hurting
somebody else, to get what they want.
But thinking they're right
is something different. Uh --
That's almost -- more evil.
A group of people who
have decided that, um --
[Trails off]
[Gleeson and Christie chuckle]
That they're morally justified
in behaving a certain way.
And I think that's what we,
kind of, approach to them. [sic]
And less like, um, a 'bad' person.
Hardwick: Sure, 'cause no character
would really go, "I am evil."
They just want what they want, and that
doesn't always jive with what everyone else wants.
Driver: Right, yeah.
Hardwick: Yeah. Perfect.
Gleeson: [indistinct] in the film, though.
I am evil.
[Laughter]
All the times.
Hardwick: Huge spoiler.
Well, Domhnall, what can you tell us
about your character?
Gleeson: I am evil.
Hardwick: Ok!
[Laughter]
Are you, though? Really?
Is your character flat-out evil?
Gleeson: Uhhm...
He's British, so, yeah.
[Laughter]
Hardwick: He's using a large
weaponized machine to obtain something.
Gleeson: Yeahh...
just like the British. Yeah.
[Laughter]
Yep. Ahh --
Hardwick: So, Gwendoline,
you are covered in, head to toe, in armor,
which I feel like
is very familiar to you.
How do you -- you know,
does that get in the way
when you're trying to
portray a character,
and you have this kind of cumbersome
stuff that you have to work around?
Or do you work it
into the character?
Christie: I found it exciting.
Because, I found it not only exciting
that there was a female stormtrooper,
[Audience cheering loudly]
But it was the opportunity
to explore a female character
that is totally not about
the way she looks in flesh.
And that armor is exterior,
and it's more like the outside feeding in.
And I just found it very exciting
that underneath that armor is a woman.
And I think it makes it really
more relevant than ever.
Hardwick: Excellent.
[Audience cheering]
I'm sure you have a couple
of questions for the Dark side,
so let's, uh, let's turn on the light
and let a couple people ask some questions.
Lights!
Oh, I'm magic.
Yes, you, sir.
>> Hello, it's good
to meet the bad guys. Um --
I wanted to know, because
I was at Star Wars Celebration,
[Scattered audience applause]
and I got to hear John
and Daisy and Oscar's story about
their reaction when
they were cast in Star Wars,
so I'd like to hear
the three new people --
what was your reaction when you found out
you were going to be in Star Wars?
Driver: Domhnall.
Gleeson: Uh, that's
what you said, really?
[Driver chuckles]
Gleeson: Uh -- no, uhm,
it was -- I met
with J.J. and, uh,
Mr. Lawrence Kasdan,
and then they told me this --
the story and who the guy was,
ehm, and that he was
in charge of people,
eh, on a star, like Starkiller Base,
sort of thing.
And -- uh-oh, hang on.
Is that alright?
Yeah, yeah, that's fine.
Abrams: That's ok.
Gleeson: Em --
[Audience laughter]
Hardwick: Do you wanna talk
about that for a second?
Gleeson: Uh, no, I don't want
to talk about it.
Unidentifiable male panelist:
What a jerk.
Abrams: Yeah, we -- the name
of the base of the First Order
is in honor of the original
last name of Luke Skywalker,
is Starkiller Base.
Spoiled by Domhnall Gleeson.
[Laughter]
[Audience clapping]
Gleeson: What else do you want to know?
What else do you want to know?
Hardwick: You can't fire him now,
so it's all in fun.
Already done. Yeah.
Uh, what about you?
What about you, Gwendoline?
Christie: I just didn't think
it could possibly really happen.
I thought that -- when I heard
it was sort of happening,
and going for fittings
and things, I still thought,
"there's every chance that they can
just replace me with someone else."
And every day was the most surreal,
bizarre experience, of --
well, you know,
like it is for all of you.
It's in such a part
of the fabric of your being,
and then you're suddenly involved in it.
Hardwick: No, I don't know
what it's like to be in Star Wars.
[Christie et al laugh]
Christie: Actually, I was just
in the car, coming here,
and kind of realized then, and thought,
"Oh, I should have thought of some things to say."
Hardwick: Yeah. Uh,
hello, what is your name, sir?
>> Hi, my name is Jonathan.
Hardwick: And what is
your question, Jonathan?
>> Is there going to be any mention
of Darth Vegas [sic: for Plagueis?]
in Episode VII? Maybe surrounding
a certain staff, that someone finds?
[Kennedy tsks, and
over-dramatically sighs]
Kenney: Is that --
Abrams: Larry? A-hem.
Do you want to answer that?
Kasdan: Uh -- I don't think I heard correctly.
Is it Darth Vegas? Like, uh, Las Vegas?
[Ridley laughs]
Kasdan: Darth F--
Vader?
Abrams: No, he's --
Larry's messing with you. Uh --
I don't think we -- we don't want to be
talking about story too much, too soon.
But, uh --
I will say, no.
[Chuckling and laughter]
Hardwick: Great, let's take -
Abrams: Thank you. Thank you.
Hardwick: You're welcome.
Let's take one more question.
Hey.
>> Hey, how's it going again?
Hardwick: Pretty sweet.
Riley: Good! [Laughs]
Hardwick: How are you?
>> Good. Uh,
Gwendoline, I just wanna say,
you're a goddess.
I think you already knew that.
[Audience cheering]
Riley: Yes.
>> Short and sweet.
Uh, cast, um, just wanna know,
are you part of the Light side
or the Dark side of the Force?
Hardwick: You mean, in real life,
you want to know?
>> I just want to know,
which is their preference.
If they had to choose --
Riley: Ohh.
Hardwick: Ok. Let's start with John.
One word answer.
Boyega: Oh, I wouldn't be involved in any of that.
I would be Han Solo, trying to make some money.
Hardwick: Yeah.
[Riley et al laugh]
[Audience applause]
Another chaotic good.
Riley: And I'd be his sidekick.
[Chuckles]
Hardwick: Oscar.
Isaac: I'll say Light side.
Light side of the Force.
Hardwick: Adam.
Driver: Dark. Dark. Dark.
[Audience chuckles]
Gleeson: Yeah, me too.
Christie: I like to go Dark.
Hardwick: [chuckles]
Excellent.
Uh, we're just gonna
suspend questions for a second.
Because at this point, I, uh --
I don't know, I thought it might
be kind of fun to, uh --
bring out Carrie Fisher!
[Audience clapping
and cheering]
Carrie Fisher: You came! Oh!
Ok. What are you doing here?
What are the odds?
All right.
[Isaac chuckles]
Hardwick: Hi, Carrie Fisher!
Fisher: [overdramatic sigh]
Oh, hi.
[Hardwick et al laugh]
[Audience member
yells something indistinct]
Hi, my darling,
how are you?
Love the hair. Ok.
Hardwick: So, can you
give us a little --
I'm sure you've been answering this question a lot,
but, we're all here, and --
Fisher: did I know it was going
to be that big of a hit?
Hardwick: [chuckles]
Well, yes, I was thinking that,
but I was afraid to ask it.
But, so my other question, uh,
is, what was the feeling like for you,
when you walked on the set,
and you saw this all come to life again?
I mean, I know you've lived
with it for a long time, but,
to see it so tangibly, and to be a part
of it again, what was that feeling like?
Fisher: It was like a flashback.
Kind of. You know, I thought --
They were right about
the, uh, acid flashbacks.
[Laughter]
No, uh --
I didn't think that it was
going to happen again.
I had to check and see if,
you know, it was just me.
Is, my voice,
coming out of my mouth.
Uh -- and no, it was --
we just -- I always said, it was...
a little bit like before,
only we looked
more melted, this time.
[Laughter]
But in a good way.
That kind of Force-melted.
Hardwick: And did it feel like
you just picked up where you left off before?
Or did it feel like
a new experience?
Fisher: Well, sort of like
we picked up where we left off,
but we left off a while ago.
So, it was a long leave-off,
and then we're back.
Thought, there were certain times,
when the three of us were standing together, and,
it was hard to, sort of, be there
and then observe an observer.
So -- but we're the legacy players.
We're known as the legacy people.
So I always think of it as kind of like
a tap dancing troupe, or something like that.
[Audience laughter]
But it was great.
And it was great
having the new people.
'Cause they do it faster.
[Panelists and audience laugh]
Hardwick: Well, you know,
speaking of legacy people,
maybe I should
bring out Mark Hamill!
[Audience cheering and clapping]
Mark Hamill: Hello, everyone.
Hello, hello.
Hardwick: Mr. Hamill.
Hamil: Yes, yes.
We have a picture
of you from 1976,
which I'm sure people have seen.
Can we throw that up there?
There's you from 1976.
Riley: Hey!
Hardwick: With the original --
I have that shirt. It's an original
Ralph McQuarrie design.
And I have -- I --
I have one of those.
Uh -- and --
[Audience chuckles]
So this was before Star Wars came out,
and you were at a fan convention,
because that was actually
a part of your life before.
What are you telling people
about Star Wars before it's come out?
Are you like, "I'm in a space movie.
I hope you see it." Like, what do you say?
At that point?
Hamill: Well, we only had photographs,
there was no footage.
And I went with Charlie Lippincott,
and I think it was in Kansas.
We had R2-D2 as a prop,
we had C-3P0, although
Anthony Daniels wasn't inside the costume.
But as you can imagine, with only 25 photographs
of various scenes in the movie,
it wasn't really easy to describe
what it was.
Um -- but --
My enthusiasm for it
was just off the charts.
And, uh, uh --
I'd been a fan -- I think my first convention
I'd ever been to was at the Ambassador Hotel in 1972.
So I was, you know, I'd been a fan since I'd caught
the black and white King Kong on television,
when I was 5 or 6 years old.
And I think the fans understand that.
I mean, you know, I'm one of them.
And they're -- obviously, over my career,
they've been a really important part of my life,
and, you know, 'cause without you guys,
we're nothing.
[Audience clapping
and cheering]
Hardwick: Is there anything --
I mean, this is --
This is a very momentous occasion,
having you guys together on stage like this.
I mean, is there anything, a message,
that you have for the fans
who've been on this journey, since 1976?
Is there anything to take away from it?
Hamill: Wow. [Chuckles] Um...
I -- I just -- like I say, the --
Well, keep coming back, yes.
But, no, uh --
You know, it's hard to describe,
because when I meet you on the street,
everyone has a story.
"I met my wife
at the premiere of Jedi,"
or, "my son is named Luke."
Or whatever it is.
It's such a personal connection.
And it's very moving to me.
It's sometimes hard to absorb
the impact you could have .
It's almost an out-of-body experience.
Uh, you know, because, uh,
it's -- I see it put together,
it's not me, it's Luke.
But, uh, I've never
taken it for granted.
And like I say, it's --
I'm moved by the connection to the world.
I mean, I've suddenly become a --
your friend, to everyone.
I mean, my wife and I went
to Tahiti on our honeymoon,
thinking, "There's nobody,
gonna know about this movie,
"way out in this paradise."
And we're on the back porch
of the little hut, on the water.
And I saw a motor boat coming towards
the back of -- coming towards us.
And as it got closer and closer and closer,
I thought I was losing my mind,
because at the helm,
was a guy
in a Darth Vader mask.
[Ridley et al laugh]
In Tahiti!
Turns out somebody bought it
in Hawaii and came to Tahiti,
they were filming a movie,
Dino De Laurentiis was making Hurricane,
and the accountant on the film
had done Star Wars.
He said, "You know
what would really surprise Mark?
"Drive up to his hut
in your Darth Vader mask!"
[Laughter]
So, uh --
Fisher: No, but it's true.
When you hear people that --
They come and
they say, you know,
"I waited to show my daughter.
I wanted to make sure I showed my kids --"
That it was something
that you can do as a family.
Hamill: Yeah.
Fisher: You want to make sure
that you show them at the right time,
and then you watch them, like,
"if we don't like the same character,
I'm not gonna like my kid!"
[Laughter]
Hamill: Yeah, it's a generational
thing now, so, you know,
my son was born when
we were doing Empire Strikes Back,
now he's, uh,
he's the real Star Wars expert
in my family.
I hate to tell you guys. I did
a Star Wars trivia contest, er, quiz,
and flunked.
[Audience laughter]
You know, I said, "I can't remember
what Han Solo was smuggling.
"Was it jewels? Or -- ?"
No, it was spices.
You know, you guys, now --
I think, ownership,
I've ceded ownership
to the world at large.
[Hardwick et al laughter]
[Audience laughter]
Years ago.
Fisher: I said
it wasn't spices.
[Laughter]
Hardwick: You crazy siblings.
Hamill: I don't want to know.
Hardwick: Uh --
J.J., how -- just, since --
There -- how --
Is Harrison ok? Has be been ok?
Abrams: Uh, well
why don't we see for ourselves!
[Audience cheering
and clapping]
Hardwick: Ladies and gentlemen,
Harrison Ford!
Harrison Ford:
Thank you. Thank you.
Hardwick: Ah, I'm sorry,
I really have to do this. I apologize.
[Ridley et al laugh]
I made them all take a picture back stage,
and I took a selfie. And I completely
blocked Harrison Ford in the picture, like an ass.
So if everyone could just
lean in a little bit, uh --
Thank you, got 'em.
Alright. Um --
First of all, thank you
for coming out, Harrison Ford.
[Audience cheering]
Fisher: Thank you.
[Cheering continues]
Hardwick: How are you feeling?
Are you feeling good? Are you feeling ok?
Ford: Yeah, I'm fine.
Hardwick: Good!
Ford: How are you?
Hardwick: I'm ok!
Ford: Good! Good --
Hardwick: I'm at a Star Wars panel.
Ford: I'm great. Yeah. I'm fine.
Thank you very much. Great.
Hardwick: They're asking
about your foot.
Ford: My foot. My foot, uh,
just walked here --
Hardwick: Yeah, he seems fine.
[Audience clapping]
Not just walked,
he bounded up the stairs.
Ford: How bad could it be?
Yeah, no, I'm good.
I really appreciate it,
thank you. Thanks for asking.
Hardwick: Yeah, of course. Good.
Ford: Thank you for asking.
Hardwick: What -- from you point of view,
walking back onto the set,
working with J.J.,
seeing the Millenium Fal --
like, what did all that
feel like, again?
Ford: [Chuckles]
Well, it should have felt ridiculous.
Uh --
[Audience laughter]
It was thirty -- you know,
it was thirty-[growly noise] years ago.
And -- and I --
sort of grew up.
And, uh --
[Audience chuckling]
And yet here I was,
doing something I did so long ago,
and...
I will tell you
that it felt great.
It felt --
[Audience cheering]
I wasn't so sure
it would, but, uh --
the company
was the right company.
The director was
the right director.
Larry wrote us
a wonderful story.
And I was proud and grateful
to, once again, be involved.
You know --
[chuckles, clears throat]
This -- the original Star Wars
that I was a part of,
really was the beginning
of my working life.
And, uh --
I was very, very grateful for
the opportunity that I had in that film,
and for the success
of that film.
And, uh -- so it was great
to be back. Thank you.
Hardwick: Of course. I mean --
[Audience clapping and cheering]
I don't think there was --
I don't think there was
one person that I knew,
when we saw that other footage
that you released, not that long ago,
and you do the,
"We're home,"
and, like, every dude
that I knew, I called, like,
"Did you cry? I cried. Did you cry, too? You cried.
I cried. I watched three times, I cried three times."
[Ridley et al chuckle]
So, we all --
We all are a part
of this as well,
and it's so meaningful that
the three of you agreed to be in this,
and really kind of
bring us home.
All together, bring us home,
in a weird sort of way.
[Audience clapping
and cheering]
So --
[Clapping and cheering continue]
Ah --
I want to, now that everyone
is out on the panel,
I would love to throw it to the audience
to ask a couple of questions,
as I'm sure you're eager to do.
So, let's start with you, sir.
Hi, what's your name?
>> Hello, my name is Bradley.
How are you?
Hardwick: Hey, Bradley!
Make sure and lean in to the microphone.
>> Will do.
Hardwick: Ok.
>> So this is a question
for the returning cast,
but if any other cast or crew want to
answer as well, feel free to do so.
What stands out to you as the biggest difference
in terms of theme in this new movie
compared to the original trilogy?
Ford: I don't know
that it's a difference in theme.
It's a development of theme.
And it's a natural
progression of the --
uh -- that has occurred from
the stories that we told in the first three.
And, uh --
perhaps a -- an emotional
rounding of the experience
that we all had
in the first three films.
Hamill: I was just glad I didn't have to go
to Tosche Station and pick up any power converters.
[Hardwick laughs]
[Audience cheering]
Fisher: I've placed information vital
to the survival of the Rebellion
in the memory systems
of this R2 unit.
I don't want
to do that again.
But I didn't have to.
We sort of, uh --
We were more
grown up this time.
I think --
Ford: It was -- yeah.
I didn't have to say
"it'll take a few minutes for the navi-computer --"
[Fisher joins in]
"-- to calculate the coordinates!"
[Laughter]
Hamill: My favorite.
Ford: Thank you, Larry.
[Hamill laughing]
Hardwick: Thank you for your question.
Hi, what's your name?
>> Hi, I'm Daniel. I had a different question,
but seeing the cast here, I have to ask.
Um --
Thank you for coming.
Fisher: That's a good question.
[Hardwick et al laugh]
What I have to -- oh.
>> Thinking back,
do you ever think that you --
what were your expectations of what your characters were going to end up in, before the movie?
Like, where did you think
Han Solo would end up?
Where did you think
Luke would have ended up?
And so forth.
Fisher: 'So forth'? That's all
I am to you, is 'so forth'?
[Laughter]
Hardwick: Oh my God!
Fisher: That's exactly --
Hardwick: You just Gilligan's-Island her!
"And the rest."
That's terrible.
Fisher: I thought it was going
to be more girly this time,
and we would do,
like, a shopping planet.
[Laughter]
And, um --
facials. Very weird
laser hair removal.
[Laughter]
Ah, but it turned out differently.
So, that was ok, too.
Hardwick: Mark?
[Fisher laughs]
Hamill: Well, I don't know. I mean,
when you find out that the only...
woman that you fell head over
heels with is your sister...
Hardwick: Yeah.
[Laughter]
Tough.
Hamill: You know, it's telling you something.
So, I had a feeling I'd probably
wind up like Sir Alec in the first one,
living in some igloo
out in the desert.
Fisher: In therapy.
Hamill: In just -- yeah, in therapy,
but with, uh, just,
no human contact,
just droids.
[Laughter]
Hardwick: You know --
first question on a date.
"You're not my sister, are you?"
"No." "Okay, good."
Hamill: Yeah, exactly.
And I want a blood test.
[Laughter]
No, seriously, 'cause that's --
I mean, we all laugh about it,
but can you -- when you follow
it through, that must have been...
quite the traumatic experience.
[Laughter]
For my character.
You know what I'm saying?
'Cause we were
both after her,
in -- in --
Ford: I know what you're saying.
[Laughter]
I mean, how many times
can I say I'm sorry?
[Hamill mock-groans]
[Laughter]
[Hamill mock-groans again]
Hamill: I'll get over it someday.
Fisher: My sister, my mother --
[Hamill joins in]
my sister, my mother.
[Laughter]
Hardwick: Harrison, do you have a thought
about where Han might have ended up?
Ford: Uh, no, it never occurred to think
about it, because I never expected, uh,
that it would, uh,
come back...
to bless me,
rather than haunt me.
It was, uh --
[Laughter]
I never thought
that we would do another,
and it was only, um --
[clears throat]
You know, the -- it was --
I was very gratified,
when I read the script,
because I read something
that I thought was
really remarkable,
really well --
well-written.
And, uh --
with some very
intriguing developments.
And, so I was delighted
to be involved.
And I was -- very happy
to be a part of this --
part of the story,
and the cast again.
Hardwick: Excellent.
Well, I want to --
[Audience cheering]
A huge hand for Star Wars: The Force Awakens.
And --
I feel like this wouldn't be
the Star Wars panel that you would be expecting,
if we just ended right there.
Um -- exactly!
[Audience cheering]
Amen to you, sister.
Uh, so --
[Ridley laughs]
JJ., what else do you have in store?
Abrams: Well, here's a question.
Um, you know,
obviously, besides
these amazing performers,
on this panel, and again,
thank you all for being here,
uh, there's another significant
star of this series, and it's the music.
[Woman in audience
yells "BB-8!"]
Ridley: Hah, BB-8!
Abrams: Who likes the music
to the Star Wars movies?
[Audience clapping
and cheering]
So, like, wouldn't it be cool
if we did something insane right now?
[Audience yells "Yes!"]
Who wants to go see
a live Star Wars concert right now?
[Audience cheering]
Hardwick: I see
a few hands are up.
Abrams: Ok, now --
Hardwick: I see a couple hands are up.
Abrams: We only have room
for all of you, so.
[Audience cheering]
So here's the thing. We're gonna
do something that is truly crazy.
And the city of San Diego
somehow said okay to this.
We are literally all going to walk
to a location together,
and we are going to experience
a Star Wars concert, tonight.
Hardwick: Now --
[Audience cheering]
[Audience still cheering]
Hardwick: Now --
Abrams: Now, in order for this to work,
in order for this to work,
this has to be done very carefully,
and I put all the responsibility
on Chris Hardwick's shoulders. Chris!
Hardwick: Ok, well sure!
Thank you!
I know, cut to tomorrow, like,
'Why am I the one getting sued?'
Ok, so, here's
a very important thing.
Here's what you
must understand.
There is room for everyone,
no murdering allowed --
[Laughter]
there's no need to push,
but in a very orderly fashion,
outside, you're gonna get,
one of these, and this is going to --
[Audience cheering]
gain you entrance.
Um, I first want to quickly introduce
and give a tremendous amount of respect
to a man by the name of Kevin Doyle,
I don't know if you say Kevin's story,
but in memory of his wife,
Kevin walked 645 miles from Rancho Obi-Wan.
[Applause]
And he's now going to
finish his walk here with us.
[Audience clapping
and cheering]
So,
Kevin is here,
and then, uh --
we all -- here he is, right here,
here's Kevin. Hello, Kevin.
Please, a huge --
[Audience cheering]
Kevin, I promise --
And some friends.
Ridley: Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh.
Hardwick: Kevin, I know
you thought you were done,
we're just gonna make
you walk a little bit more,
they're gonna follow you,
so here's what --
in order for this to work,
everyone has to --
I know you're taking pictures,
and you're not listening to me,
and I feel like you're my children right now,
and I need you to focus.
Put down your damn computers,
and let's -- ok.
Ok, pictures,
pictures, pictures.
Ok, listen to me.
[Woman in audience yell something]
Ok, good, thank you.
Um, you're gonna follow these Stormtroopers
in an orderly fashion,
there is absolutely
no need to push,
uh, because we don't
want this to turn into a tragic event,
we want to be happy,
we're all happy that we're here,
we're seeing stuff
no one's ever seen before,
and we're all gonna go see
a Star Wars concert together, everyone,
so please --
[Audience cheering]
I'm going to let our panel go.
Would you please leap to your feet
and give me a huge round of applause
for the Star Wars:
The Force Awakens.
Oh, I'm sorry.
[Audience cheering]
And honestly, J.J --
Thank you so --
you're gonna follow
these guys in an orderly fashion.
This has been an absolute
dream of mine,
I can't tell you how important
this has been,
Thank you for being here
and being a part of it.